vermine moisissures et problèmes de
chauffage à saint laurent des locataires
vivent des conditions d'insalubrité
absolument invraisemblable la ville a
d'ailleurs émis plus de 1200 constats
d'infraction propriétaire des lieux et
aucune amélioration d' encore été
apportée au logement
émilie dubreuil moi je fais mais dans
cette maison la bienvenue chez emmanuel
et qui paye 380 $ par mois pour se loger
ici dans la cuisine praticable un
immense trou au plafond souris coquerel
une salle de bains dysfonctionnelle tout
ça en plus du froid
nous voici dans l'appartement d'un autre
locataire de la même adresse
en fait ce que nous allons voir dans cet
immeuble est à l'avenant et les
locataires ont peur souffre d'anxiété
comment vous allez le coc émotions
l'immeuble où il habite appartient à
shang oggi seulement à cette adresse
l'homme a reçu pas moins de 651 constats
d'infraction le même propriétaire
possède sur la même rue les immeubles du
11750 et 11760 total d'infractions pour
les deux adresses 622 moisissures
infiltrations d'eau punaises de lit
mesures de sécurité déficientes
pourtant chaque goudji n'a pas encore
été mis à l'amendé n'a pas dû verser un
sou à la ville centre qui gère le
dossier
on a encore l'espoir que le propriétaire
vos réels et les travaux le pour le
moment seulement dans le cadre d'un
programme de subventions yahoo 300000
d'oran de travaux qui vont se faire il y
a près d'un an lors de notre dernière
visite sur la rue ranger la ville avait
ordonné l'évacuation de six logements
que le propriétaire devait rénover
c'est en mettant des locataires qui
avaient été délogées
depuis il habite dans un autre
appartement tant de conditions
semblables
c'est pas une vie la vérité si c'est pas
un d il ya douze la joie qui vont devoir
être évacués
aujourd'hui rémy patrice du comité
logement ahuntsic cartierville viennent
à viser les locataires qu'ils ont des
recours
encore une fois la ville procède à
l'évacuation de 12 logements au 11750 le
propriétaire n'a rien fait depuis un an
ou presque rien fait d'où la raison de
l'évacuation actuellement il n'y a pas
nui de la mangue le propriétaire reçoit
une subvention pour faire des travaux
pour nous le sert et c'est souvent ce
n'est la déléguée de la délinquance
l'hôte et les propriétaires selon des
témoins chan broggi que nous avions
rencontré l'an dernier aurait proposé de
loger les évacués du 11750 2815 là où
habite emmanuel émilie dubreuil radio
canada montréal